Let's do this.
Keep everyone alive.
Holy geez.
Hiya!
The nine ring broadsword.
NARRATOR: The nine
ring broadsword
is a variant on the Chinese
dao from the Qing dynasty
that was used through the 1930s.
Featuring a blade wider than
a traditional dao and a curve
towards the tip, the weapon
was ideal for chopping
and could sever a head
with a single swing.
The rings on the
back of the blade
serve dual purposes,
for ornamentation used
during ceremonies or
martial arts displays
and for superstitious
reasons, as it
was believed that jingling sound
would ward off evil spirits.
This deadly and sacred sword
can be seen on the television
show "Into the Badlands."
Bladesmiths, you
have our gratitude.
Gentlemen, your swords
look magnificent,
but are they deadly?
To find that out, we
will take your swords
and deliver some clean
blows on this pig carcass.
It's all about the kill
in this particular test.
Britain, you are first.
Are you ready, sir?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
Well, there it went.
All right, Britain, first up.
What I love about this
blade was the balance,
the way I was able to move
with the blade everywhere.
Now let's talk
about the breakage.
OK, so the break
happened right there
where the ring was attached.
You can see it's really not a
bad [inaudible] you have there.
It could be finer, but rings,
when you're digging into that,
could cause stress risers.
And it broke right there
where the ring was.
Well gentlemen, the fight
is not over, because Mike,
your blade still has
to survive nine strikes
on its kill test target.
Good luck, gentlemen.
Doug.
If I make it through
nine strikes on this pig,
I'm Forged in Fire champion.
My palms are sweating.
I'm so scared that
this thing is going
to break on the first swing.
Good job, Bro.
Burton, unfortunately
your blade broke.
It can no longer
continue with testing.
And for that reason, I have
dismiss you from the forge.
You did a good job, brother.
I appreciate that.
It sucks.
Gorgeous weapon.
Thank you, man.
Seeing my blade break,
it's a disappointment.
You know, when you make it to
round three, you want to win.
You know, the nine holes
burnt through four drill bits
doing them, so
somewhere through there
I probably was giving a
little too much pressure
and caused the stress riser
to run down that blade.
That was enough to cause a
critical failure in that blade.
I'm still proud of myself
with what I've done, you know.
It was a way out
of my wheelhouse.
What's next for
me is not swords,
especially any nine ring
swords, that's for damn sure.
Mike, congratulations.
The strength and
integrity of your blade
has made you a Forged
in Fire champion
and that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
I won Forged in Fire.
Holy crap, man.
Come on forward and
shake our hands, my friend.
Thank you.
- Good job.
- Thank you.
Some of the things that
went wrong in my home
forge, I was really
sure that that blade
was going to break on me.
But it didn't.
This is a happy dance.
Do it all day.
The Tuareg takouba.
The takouba is a
type of broadsword
that has been used by the
nomadic Tuareg people of North
Africa since the 14th century.
This double-edged
lightweight blade
was carried for self-defense
on long journeys,
designed to deliver
lethal slashes and stabs
against a rival warrior.
Due to the Tuareg's
aversion to iron,
there is no exposed steel or
iron on the hilt of the sword,
so it cannot touch
the user's hand.
Measuring more
than a meter long,
this deadly weapon was
seen as a symbol of wealth.
Some members of the Takouba clan
still carry this weapon today.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
Your Taureg takoubas
look beautiful,
but the kind of beauty I'm
looking for is the lethal kind.
I'm going to take your weapon,
deliver some lethal blows
to this ballistics dummy.
Dustin, you're first.
Ready?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[rock music playing]
[laughing]
All right, Dustin.
Let's talk about
your weapon here.
First up, your
handle construction.
I like the ovoid feel of this.
The flare you have
there in your pummel
actually gives great
retention for this.
Your tip is sharp
enough to penetrate,
your edges are sharp
when you're cutting out,
and you can wield this
to do that kind of damage
on this ballistic dummy.
Overall, sir, a weapon
like this, it will kill.
Awesome.
All right, Joshua.
Your turn.
You ready?
Keep everyone alive.
All right, let's do this.
[rock music playing]
All right.
Joshua, let's talk
about your weapon here.
Your pummel right here could
have used some weight to it,
but because it's forward
weighted and the fact
that you have a very sharp edge,
every slice that you can see
is very deep into
the ballistics dummy.
And more importantly, sir,
your weapon, it will kill.
Yeah.
All right, gentlemen, it's
time for the strength test.
Our desert well chop.
Now, to test the strength
and overall construction
of your blades, I will
be chopping into our well
house as well as the well.
Dustin, you're on deck.
You ready?
I guess so.
OK.
[rock music playing]
All right.
We were doing so well
for a moment there.
What actually happened was,
with insetting your blade down
into this piece of wood,
any of that leverage
was just too much for the wood
itself and it popped it loose.
Your tang is a little bit
small, but what I do like to see
is that your blade actually
held up beautifully.
I mean, your grain
structure looks fine.
This is an absolutely
brutal test.
Very well done.
Thank you.
Now, Dustin, you survived
every one of the strikes
except for the last one.
Your guard gave way and
your blade followed.
So we consider this a
catastrophic failure.
Cannot continue
testing your blade.
But you're not out
of the fight yet.
How are you feeling, Joshua?
Pressure's on.
All right.
So you need to survive
five strikes in order to be
named Forged in Fire champion.
Are you ready?
Yes, sir.
All right.
Let's do it.
[rock music playing]
Well, Joshua, your
blade is strong.
It made it past all the strikes.
Congratulations.
Now Dustin, unfortunately for
you that means your time here
in this competition has
ended because you did
have a catastrophic failure.
It was an honor watching
you in our forge,
but unfortunately,
man, at this time
I'm going to have
to ask you to please
step off our forge floor.
Thank you guys.
Thank you so much.
I'm definitely crushed.
I actually thought that
recessing the sword
into the tang a little bit
would make it stronger,
and that's kind of what
bit me in the end, so
definitely definitely
won't be doing that again.
I'm definitely
proud of this blade.
I came here to challenge
myself as much as I could
and I definitely achieved that.
Well Joshua,
congratulations man.
That means you are the newest
Forged in Fire champion.
You just got yourself
a check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
I made a sword
that didn't break.
Oh my gosh.
It was a hard competition,
so this is unreal.
Oh.
The Polish karabela.
NARRATOR: One of Europe's
most iconic sabers,
the karabela was a side
arm of history's most
fearsome cavalry,
the Winget hussars.
These 17th century warriors
famed for their feathered armor
and sophisticated
attack formations,
brandished the
sword on horseback
when closing in on the enemy.
The saber's light
curved blade slashed
easily through enemy armor.
Its hilt often
included fixtures that
improved grip and recovery,
like a thumb ring, chain guard,
or curved eagle head pummel.
The karabela was so effective
at helping the hussars defeat
enemy armies much
larger in size,
that it became a
symbol of prestige
worn by Polish Lithuanian
nobility at formal events.
Its legacy lives on in the
video game series "Witcher."
Bladesmiths, this
is the kill test.
To see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do,
I will take your weapon,
deliver some slashes
and thrusts on this pig carcass.
Ethan, you're up first.
You ready?
I am so ready.
[rock music playing]
All right How'd it feel?
First up, there are
no issues whatsoever
with your edge over here.
It is sharp.
It lacerates and cuts cleanly.
Look at that razor
cuts right there.
On the thrust you
have an angle here
that allowed for a deep
thrust, pulling out
and slashing on the way out.
Overall your weapon will kill.
All right.
Liam, your turn.
You ready?
- Oh, yeah.
Let's do it.
So many things can go wrong.
I don't even know if I was
able to get a good solid temper
on this blade.
[rock music playing]
Well, Liam, let me say this.
First up, your presence
here is a victory.
All the things that
you went through
and you still turn in a
blade that's beautiful
in craftsmanship
that is very sharp.
But your blade did
break and you can
see right here in the
cross section there's
just a discoloration down here.
So something happened in
your heat treating process.
It may have micro fractures.
It is what it is.
Liam, there was a
flaw in your blade
that led to a
catastrophic blade failure
and we can no longer
continue with testing.
For that reason, I have to ask
you to please leave the forge.
Thank you gentlemen.
I'm upset.
Sometimes the best you can
do isn't going to be enough,
but that doesn't mean,
you shouldn't still try.
Ethan, this is a competition
where the best player wins
and you, sir, are new
Forged in Fire champion,
and that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job.
I really would have liked
to have seen both of those
go all the way through
testing, but I'm
very proud of the work I did.
And now Forged in Fire champion.
[howling]
Attila the Hun's
Sword of Mars.
Yes.
NARRATOR: Known as
the Scourge of God,
Attila the Hun was
one of the most
feared conquerors in history.
The leader of the Hunnic Empire,
his group of nomadic tribes
wreaked havoc across Europe
during the fifth century.
Though he was once a
great ally to them,
he plauged Roman territories,
sacking major cities
like Constantinople.
Legend states that Attila
was given the Sword of Mars
by a herdsman, fulfilling a
prophecy and a direct sign
from the Roman war god,
Mars, of his divine rule.
The lethal weapon featured
a curved handle with a spear
point tip that gave it
exceptional control,
allowing for accurate
and brutal thrusts.
After Attila's death
in the year 453,
the Hunnic Empire
quickly dissolved.
However, the story of
Attila's many conquests
still live on through the
television miniseries "Attila."
All right, bladesmiths.
To find out what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do,
I will deliver killing blows
on this ballistics dummy.
Randy, you're up first.
You ready?
I am.
Let's do this.
[rock music playing]
All right.
[inaudible] let's talk about
your Sword of Mars here.
First up, the Damascus pattern
you have here is gorgeous.
Thank you.
The weapon design is very
aggressive for thrusting
and slashing.
Now, your handle construction.
If you reverse this,
it'll be easier to have
something to lock on to.
The fact that the
flare is right here,
forcing my hand to open up if
I want to marry into the hilt.
This is a very sharp weapon.
The tip pierces all the way
through, cuts on the way out.
It's pointy and scary
and it will kill.
Thank you.
Good job.
All right, Dan.
It is your turn.
Are you ready?
Hell yeah.
Let's do this.
I was hoping the kill
test would be a dummy.
I know heads will roll.
[rock music playing]
All right, Dan.
Let's talk about
your weapon here.
I love the balance
of your blade.
When I go forward, it's
not hard to pull back to go
in again for another kill.
Now your handle construction.
It's curved enough
to where it doesn't
want to fly out of my hand.
It's got a good grip
and control for this.
Your edge allows for very
deep cuts into the abdomen
right there.
The only issue we have is
that your tip picked up a bend
when it chopped into the spine.
But your weapon, sir, will kill.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen, it's
time for the strength test.
Now, Attila's armies were
basically one large cavalry,
and through his
military campaigns
he revolutionized the use of
horse in military conflicts.
So to test the strength and
durability of your blades,
I'll be chopping into
these horse skulls.
Randy, you're up first.
Are you ready?
I guess so.
[rock music playing]
OK, so right off the
bat the biggest thing
is that this section, from
right about here to here,
has lost its edge.
There's a couple of small roles.
Blade's still straight.
It's all in one piece.
Still solid.
Nicely done.
It's a very strong blade.
- Thank you.
- All right.
Dan, are you ready?
No, but let's do it.
Everybody says that.
[rock music playing]
[inaudible]
OK, so before we
get to the obvious,
I really like the
design of your blade.
It's got a great weight to it.
Had a really good
feel in my hand.
The balance was really nice.
See all that space
around your tang?
With that room for that blade
to move inside the guard,
it could just create so much
stress that it cut loose
right there at the corner.
If it were all tight, there
wouldn't be any stress.
There's no
discoloration here so,
it's not that there was
a crack here before.
The grain structure looks fine.
It was a well designed
piece, but obvious flaw.
Dan, unfortunately your blade
suffered a catastrophic failure
in the middle of
our strength test,
which means that we
can no longer test it.
I'd like to invite you
to shake our hands,
shake your competitor's
hand, and then
please leave the forge.
It hurts, but my
sword breaking, it's
going to be a
reminder that I have
to push harder and be better.
Randy, the strength and
efficiency of your weapon
in the kill test have
earned you the title
of Forged in Fire champion
and a check for how much?
$10,000.
That's right. $10,000.
Good job, brother.
I won Forged in Fire.
That's reality.
How do you feel?
Good.
To be a champion and be
recognized as a good bladesmith
is real good.
This is my happy
and excited face.
Well done, sir.
Thank you.
If you didn't recognize it.
The sodegarami.
Holy geez.
Oh my god.
NARRATOR: One of the most
intimidating and versatile
Japanese pole weapons,
the sodegarami
was part of the key
arsenal for samurai police
during the 17th century.
Featuring lethal
spikes and hooks,
police were able to
capture violent offenders
from a distance by
using the weapon
to latch onto the suspects,
stopping them in their tracks.
Although primarily
used in defense,
the sharp spikes, along
with the spike bud cap
made it a menacing and
brutal weapon when in combat.
Today, the sodegarami's
devastating use
can be seen in the HBO
television series "Westworld."
All right, bladesmiths.
Welcome to the kill test.
To find out what kind of lethal
damage your sodegarami will do,
I will take your
weapons and stab
and try to snag this
ballistics dummy.
Rita, you're up first.
You ready for this?
- Hai.
- All right.
Let's do this.
[rock music playing]
All right.
Let's talk about
your sodegarami.
The tines you have
here penetrates.
The hook you have here
will rip this person apart,
and more importantly,
your weapon will kill.
All right, Justin.
Your turn.
You ready to have fun?
Yes, sir.
[rock music playing]
All right, Justin.
The tines you have here,
it's more of a stabbing tine
rather than a grabbing.
This is a grabbing weapon.
But that hook does
grab onto that.
Overall, sir, your weapon?
Will kill.
All right, bladesmiths.
It's time for the strength test.
The dreaded ice block chop.
Remember, this is not
about what these weapons do
to the ice blocks,
but what those ice
blocks do to your weapons.
And Rita, you're up first.
You get points for theme.
I mean-- You ready?
It doesn't matter, right?
No, it doesn't matter.
[rock music playing]
All right, Rita.
Got a little bit more of
a bend in this one tine
here, but everything
else is pretty
much the way it was going in.
Definitely held up.
Did its job.
Good job.
Thank you.
All right, Justin.
Your turn.
You ready?
Yes I am.
[intense music playing]
All right, so you
survived the strength test.
This is a very strong,
well-built head for this,
but it's built more like a
spear than it is for catching.
I mean, I'm not sure
how effective it would
be at snagging the opponent,
but to devastate her,
it certainly did the job.
Good job.
All right, bladesmiths,
welcome to the sharpness test,
the Sandman Pierce and Capture.
To test the sharpness,
I will take your weapon,
pierce, and tried to
control this sandman.
Rita, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Yeah.
[rock music playing]
All right Rita.
The points you have
on your tines here
definitely penetrate when
you thrust into that,
but doesn't slice on
the way out or capture
as well as it should.
Your hook over here did its job.
Overall, it will
cut and control.
All right, Justin.
Your turn.
So you ready?
Yes I am.
[rock music playing]
Oh.
That's not good.
He pulled it
out of the socket.
Well, Justin,
we have a problem.
Yes, sir.
This wasn't pinned was it?
No.
The impact from all
these tests loosened it up,
and of course it came off.
Justin, you brought in a
beautifully crafted weapon,
however you've suffered
a catastrophic failure
in our final test.
And unfortunately, you cannot
be our Forged in Fire champion.
Congratulations, Rita.
Thank you.
Awesome.
Coming on Forged in
Fire, I put my all into it.
And I feel like I
made a good weapon
but just came up
short on a little bit
of the fit and finish.
And other than that,
I'm happy with it.
Rita, congratulations.
You are the Forged
in Fire champion
and that is a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
How do you feel right now?
I just--
Come on forward
and shake our hands.
Good job.
It's been a very
positive and uplifting
experience to be able to do
something amazing like this.
I hope this will help me
become an inspiration to kids
because I can say, look,
if you see something
and you want to try
it, give it a try.
Hey, Weeblos, your scout
leader is the new Forged
in Fire champion.
I'm bringing it home.
Can I have a group hug?
Please?
Thank you guys.
Oh my God.
[rock music playing]